[Music]
all right thank you very much this is
the second afternoon panel we'll be
hearing about fairness and this is going
to be moderated by our very own and
Hannah Wallach from our sister lab MSR
New York so take it off great okay so
now that nicole has told you all to sit
down I want you all to stand back up
great okay now I want you to either
jump up and down and stretch okay now
you can sit back down all right so I
want this to be an interactive panel and
I want people to ask questions and so I
wanted to make sure you were all paying
attention good all right
so as Nicole said I'm Hannah for those
of you who don't know me I'm a principal
researcher in Microsoft Research New
York and an adjunct professor at UMass
Amherst and my background is in machine
learning and specifically I study
machine learning and society
so I both use machine learning to study
society and I study the effect that
machine learning has on society as
machine learning and AI are becoming
much more common and widespread and over
the past few years I've been
concentrating specifically on issues of
fairness accountability transparency and
ethics as they relate to AI and machine
learning indeed that is the topic of
today's panel unsurprisingly and I think
it's a really important and timely topic
so I'm really glad that we're having
this panel discussion on this here today
so at this point it's pretty clear that
we're kind of living in the age of AI
machine learning is everywhere and at
least for the moment it looks like it's
here to stay and this is great this is
great for researchers like me this is
great for companies like Microsoft but
at the same time we're also seeing that
these kinds of opportunities also raise
new challenges and challenges that have
received a lot of attention in the media
recently and have really highlights at
how important it is that we get AI right
that we don't let
discriminate or disadvantage previously
disadvantaged groups so how many of you
have seen one of these stories great so
pretty much everyone that's what I was
hoping for good so then you'll know that
this is a really complicated and fraught
landscape with a lot of different key
stakeholders ranging from yesh or
researchers but companies like Microsoft
the government civil rights and civil
liberties organizations and of course
the people who use these technologies
and who are affected by these
technologies in their lives so we have a
really accomplished group of panelists
here today to meet gabru Debbie Hellman
Adam Kauai and Mira Lane and they're
gonna explore this landscape here today
and in turn I hope that you'll walk away
from this panel with a deeper
understanding of why these issues are so
important why they're non-trivial why
they really get at the core of the
relationship between technology and
society and why it's important that we
take them really seriously even when
there are no obvious right answers so
here's how this is going to go I am
gonna start by briefly introducing the
panelists and then I'm gonna ask each
panelist to talk for a few minutes about
themselves their own work and how their
work relates to the topics of fairness
accountability transparency and ethics
and then what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
ask them a series of questions to get
the discussion going and after that I'm
gonna hand the floor over to you and
this is really your opportunity I'm sure
many of you have questions about these
topics that you really want to know the
answers to this is your opportunity to
ask them okay and if at any time you
want to ask a question either while the
panelists are talking about their own
work or while I'm asking questions you
should feel free to do so just raise
your hand and I will wave at Nicole and
she will run a mic over to you
okay wonderful great so with that I'm
gonna introduce our panelists okay so to
meet gabru Joe
finished her postdoc in the fate group
at Microsoft Research New York and we
miss her a lot she is now a research
scientist in the ethical AI team at
Google AI and she's currently studying
the ethical considerations underlying
any data mining project and methods of
auditing and mitigating bias in socio
technical systems as a co-founder of the
group black in AI she works to both
increased diversity in the field and to
reduce the negative impacts of racial
bias and training data used for human
centric machine learning models great so
Debbie Hellman is the dealer tan Massey
professor of law in the University of
Virginia School of Law and her work
focuses on discrimination both from a
philosophical and a legal perspective
she's particularly interested in the
questions what is discrimination and
what makes it wrong in fact she wrote a
book called when is discrimination wrong
in 2008 and has continued to work on
these topics in the years since she's
also new to AI and therefore wants you
to know that you shouldn't ask her
anything super technical okay Adam Adam
kalaiy is a very serious principal
researcher in Microsoft Research New
England although he is better known as
the husband of Yale Cal I Adam has had
over 50 papers rejected Counting
multiple submissions multiple times in
top computer science venues only the
best for Adam the last time I moderated
a panel that Adam was on he made a fool
of me I am going to get my revenge and
[Laughter]
our final panelist is marilaine who is
the potted director of ethics and
society
within cloud and AI at Microsoft she has
a background in art computer science and
mathematics and she holds numerous
patents across platforms and
collaborative interfaces Mira's team is
responsible for guiding technical and
experience innovation towards ethical
responsible and sustainable outcomes so
please join me in welcoming our
panelists okay so now we're gonna have
the panelists each talk a little bit
about their work and how it relates to
fairness accountability transparency and
ethics and I think maybe what we'll do
since I started with Tim neat before I
will start with Mira this time okay so
as Hanna was saying I am part of the
engineering team at Microsoft I'm not
part of Microsoft research but what
you've heard over and over again and all
of the panels is a need for a bridge
between research and what's happening on
the applied side and so my team acts as
a bridge and we do is we take ideas and
policies that are happening in research
and across Microsoft and then we look at
those and say how do we bring these into
an engineering context and how do we
apply these so that thousands of
engineers designers product thinkers
sales folks can then do responsible
things with technology this involves
everything from looking at how we
collect data how we do scenario planning
how we look at impact and consequences
of our work how we actually develop and
where we set benchmarks in our code and
then how we maintain our systems at the
once they've gone out the door and so
this is a new type of model in the
company I don't think anything like this
quite exists and so it's an experiment
we're innovating and we're trying new
things but it's a fairly big investment
there's about 20 people working on this
it's a multidisciplinary group there's
social psychologists on the team they're
developers designers storytellers
creative coders and and so we're playing
around when this space and we're trying
to bring responsible thinking and
responsible innovation into a complex
and gnarly space where we look at speech
technologies facial recognition we do
things around virtual reality in
hololens and so a lot of the gnarly
things that you tend
seeing the news are in this group that
I'm working on I'm a machine learning AI
researcher and you could think of me as
the naive user of AI machine learning
that would have naturally you know made
algorithms that discriminate except that
I'm in this lab surrounded by people
like this and many other people in our
lab and and you know they made us think
before oh gee maybe we should think a
little bit about what these technologies
will do and then we started doing that
and then covering various biases that we
saw in words that you might see gender
bias or race racial biases and what
effects that would have on various
algorithms we designed so we are also
thinking about how we might deal with it
great Thank You Adam okay okay I hope
I'm not gonna talk for too long because
those were shorter but I thought I'd
tell you about a paper I'm working on
now just because I always think it's
interesting to hear what people are
working on and because it's a great
resource it's a little bit selfish great
resource for me in case you guys have
some input I would love to hear it
because as I said I'm a bit of an
interloper here so I'm working on a
paper that has to do with the
controversy about the compass risk
assessment tool which I imagine most of
you are familiar with I see most heads
nodding but just briefly it's a risk
assessment tool that's used to determine
who should get out of prison early on
parole it's also used in bail settings
in many many states around the country
and there was a big brouhaha after an
expose by ProPublica which alleged that
the tool discriminated between blacks
and whites and didn't treat them fairly
and the response from the company that
makes compass which is north point was
to say that's not true the tool does
treat blacks and whites fairly or
doesn't discriminate between blacks and
whites and the upshot of that debate was
that they were focusing on different
measures that Northpoint was focusing on
one measure for assessing whether blacks
and whites are treated equally and
ProPublica and the critics of compass
were focusing focusing on another
measure that led to then a series of
papers by people like you all that
showed that in many many contexts in
fact in most contexts it would be in
possible to equalize with regard to both
measures that is you couldn't treat
blacks and whites equally with regard to
the measure that Northpoint was focusing
on and at the same time with the with
regard to the measure that ProPublica
was focusing on thus leading to the
question which one should we prefer and
why and in the second series of papers
that looked at that question that second
generation question was posed as which
measure of fairness should we prefer and
why and where I want to intercede in
this debate is to say that there's
something wrong with that framing that
they're not both measures of fairness
and so we're not comparing two things in
the same domain that one of the measures
is a measure of fairness and the other
measure maybe has some implications for
fairness but isn't itself a measure of
fairness so just if I can say a few more
words the two measures the one that
Northpoint was focusing on was if two
people get a risk score of let's say
eight out of ten that a black person and
a white person who both get a score of
eight are equally likely to recidivate
that is eight out of ten people who get
that score will in fact recidivate so
the score was equally predictive for
both groups so it was an equal
predictive accuracy and that was true
for foreign north for the compass jewel
the folk the measure that ProPublica was
focused on was not asking if you got a
score what was the likelihood that you
would recidivate was but was asking the
question in a different kind of way was
saying if you were someone who was at
low risk for recidivating what's the
likelihood that the tool would
accurately characterize you as low risk
and there there was a big difference
between how a low risk black and a low
risk white person were characterized by
the tool a low risk black person was
much more likely to be mischaracterized
by the tool than a low risk white person
so the the another way of characterizing
this would be to say that the scores
were equally accurate they had equal
predictive act
see but of course they weren't perfect
and when there were mistakes the
mistakes went in different directions
one had more forest positives than the
other Moore's more false negatives so
then the question is which measure do we
care about equal predictive accuracy or
equalizing the error rates the false
positives and false negative rates and
what I'm arguing in this paper which I'm
happy to talk to you more about in the
QA or in coffee is that the measure that
looked at equalizing the error rates is
a measure of fairness because it's
looking at what's the burden of mistakes
how are are the burdens of mistakes
falling equally on the two groups so it
relates to the way in which we treat
people
whereas equal predictive accuracy is
about what we believe about people that
is it's about belief versus action that
is if the scores don't have equal
predictive accuracy a score of eight
will mean something different for a
black person versus a white person if we
give up on predictive accuracy and
therefore I won't know what to believe
about a person who has a score of eight
I won't know what to believe about what
that means about the likelihood that he
or she will recidivate but a score that
relates to what I ought to believe
versus what I ought to do is not related
to fairness in any straightforward way
and that's the basic conceptual point of
the paper is that predictive accuracy
relates to belief error rate balance
relates to action and therefore is more
naturally a fairness based concern I'm
glad you brought up the compass data set
because so I I was I studied computer
vision and the only interest I had was
in studying computer vision but Torstein
and my PhD I read that for trouble car
article and I was terrified and so
that's kind of how I started to get more
interested in these
questions of issues and fairness so my
PhD was in using computer vision to do
visual data mining so for example using
images to predict things about society
and that naturally has certain biases
the kinds of biases that we might
discuss and so that's when I realized
even my own work kind of suffers from
these issues of fairness and so I then
met joy bola meanie who is the advisee
of ethan who was moderating the prior
panel and we worked on a paper showing
that there are disparities in the
commercial face recognition systems in
how accurate they are for different
subgroups of people so we looked at skin
types
we used a dermatology classification
system for skin tone and gender and and
in addition to you know my work in
computer vision and this work I view
what for me equally important is to make
sure that the voices of the people who
are unfairly affected by these systems
are amplified so for example because
diversity gives you domain knowledge
right so joy Balam Amy she's a much
darker skinned black woman and so the
reason that she came up with this idea
of using Fitzpatrick's skin type rather
than race which a lot of people had done
this kind of analysis with race is
because of her domain knowledge about
colorism about a whole bunch of other
things so i think equally important is
to make sure that the people who bring
this domain knowledge that their voices
are amplified great thanks everyone
ok so I'm gonna start with some
questions and the first question which I
want to ask really is sort of a overview
question and kind of stage setting
question is what are the different ways
that one might think about whether a
decision or output obtained via an AI
based system treats people fairly or not
and I'm gonna kick that question over to
you Debbie because of your background in
discrimination so the first point I
would emphasize about that is that
there are different ways of answering
that question and people disagree about
that and so that's what's interesting
anyway about it so obviously one way
that people think about what fairness is
is the idea of treating like cases alike
and I think many people strive for that
idea I don't think that's the only way
of thinking about it and I think we make
a mistake if we emphasize that too much
but that is obviously one way of
thinking about what fairness is is
treating my cases like another way would
be treating everybody literally the same
that's not that plausible in most
situations but another idea a third way
is one that you mentioned before which
is making sure not to disadvantage
already disadvantaged groups a fourth
way which is we see dominant in legal
discourse is just avoiding the use of
certain traits or classifications
that's another conception oh and then a
fifth one might be not doing things that
are demeaning in some way and that is
not an exhaustive list but just gives
you a flavor of possibilities do any of
the rest of you have anything to add to
that well I think one of the things to
sort of add to that is if we look back
into again the engineering system having
a robust set of test cases that we can
then go and apply against the systems to
say what kinds of discrimination might
be happening in the system is very
important because one of the things we
don't do right now is actually separate
out those subgroups and the categories
of people that might be using a system
and it's something that we're trying to
build into the new way that we design
advanced technologies and look at well
we know that the system is going to
impact these classes of people and we
know that some of these are vulnerable
audiences and how do we proactively go
and in you know investigate the system
to see how they're performing against
certain subgroups and then go in and set
benchmarks and say okay your code cannot
go out the door if it doesn't meet a
certain criteria across all of these
different subgroups and there's a lot of
work that we need to do to even get
there but that's how I would take what
your what your
and translated into getting the system
to perform a certain way because the
thing that I worry about the most is
that we end up talking about it a lot
but then we don't go and change the
system in such a way that it performs in
a way that is fair or it puts fairness
into the system and and I don't think
enough work is happening in that space
right now which is why if it's so
important to me to go and and be that
bridge between all the great work that
you guys are doing and then the
engineers who are not necessarily
thinking about this problem space in the
same way that this group is oh yes yes
which is trying to basically say if
you're going to let's say let's take a
face recognition system and before you
have a pre trained model or an API
available like how about you tell us
some of the tests that you've done some
of the false positive rates all false
negative rates or you know we have a
whole host of tests but I'm just making
it fun so that I say one tweet yeah
we're gonna well I was going to say for
data sheets we've actually been spending
a lot of time so I'll I'll give you the
high level view and then maybe Hannah
you can come in and say Mira this is
maybe there's a more robust way to talk
about it but when I when I talk about
data sheets to our engineers I say these
are basically nutrition labels for data
sets so when you look at a data set you
won't understand the composition of it
what's inside it how it was collected
how can you use the data so that if
you're going in using this data in
another model that you might be training
you have a sense for what that data can
be used for and how that data is
performing against other things yeah Tim
that you should yeah that's that's
that's basically so there's two two
parts of so data sheets is four data
sets and I think it would be helpful for
even you know when people are sharing
data sets internally because a lot of
times somebody collects a data set uses
it for one purpose and another team
gets that data to try to use it for
another purpose and then some
information is lost when you transfer
right you don't know what the original
reason was that the data set was
collected for you don't know what the
legal considerations are you don't know
what the intended use cases are etc etc
so I think the first step so we talked
about fairness accountability
transparency I think this is a
low-hanging fruit and transparency I
think there's a lot we can do and
transparency that we're not doing and so
another the follow-up paper that I've
just mentioned is a similar thing for
models right because when we were
initially writing data sheets we were
thinking about datasets and models but
it turned out that it's it's actually
very complicated to even just do this
idea for four datasets but then it's oh
but then there's a second part to it
which is when you're releasing a model
or an API like I've just talked about a
paper we wrote with joy where we were
auditing commercial gender
classification systems right what kind
of information are you giving the user
are you giving them intended viewed
cases are you giving them disclaimers
like don't use this to you know decide
whether someone is a criminal or not so
that's that's the follow-up in terms of
models so I just wanted to push back on
one thing that you say that's okay Marin
of course the idea that you're gonna
kind of audit the I don't know what word
you use but something like that the
system's you still need to say what your
audited in them for right and so if
you're auditing them for the idea of
treating like cases alike versus
auditing them for the idea
disadvantaging previously disadvantaged
groups those are often gonna yield
so it doesn't audit them for fairness
but to expect that we have different
views about what that is there's one
more kind of fairness that you didn't
mention which is very widely you know a
very common one which is just that if
your system was trained with any kind of
data then its objective and its fair
which is a wily heavily I don't believe
it but I think in some ways you know the
data sheets work speaks to that and it
says to people well think about what
they did you used it's not but but it is
a belief that a lot of people have and
that's one that would kind of need to
dispel but it is many people find that
intuitive or that's their first reaction
oh this came with data therefore it's
probably fair they can just you know
justifying things with data is a
standard way to justify making decisions
which isn't always fair so I'm
interested in digging a little bit
further into this idea of sort of how
each of you thinks about fairness or
even measures fairness when it comes to
AI based systems and as you said Debbie
there's a whole bunch of different kind
of metrics or measures that you can look
at there are various different
trade-offs between them and some types
of unfairness might be just inherently
very difficult to even quantify or to
automate so I'm interested from all of
you to to learn a little bit more about
which which approaches which measures
which metrics do you do you use how do
you think about testing for fairness I
wanted to I mean actually this was a
question I wanted to ask that me too
I'm wondering so the way I think about
it is I don't have anything to add to
the additional up to the metrics that
you mentioned but I wonder you know I
think it's context specific - right like
which one which metric to use for what
purpose and so one of when we were
talking about auditing systems the way I
think about it is have to just audit it
for a whole bunch of different metrics
that people have come up with and then
maybe when you know they when you know
the context you know sometimes maybe
having false positives is the word is is
worse than something else right and so
maybe then the person
using the system can make a decision
about if this system is appropriate or
not what do you think about late what is
your opinion on this type of approach do
you think we should have just one or two
metrics that we all agree on and so from
there or I agree with you that different
contexts call for different things right
that if I'm trying to decide whether to
put someone in jail you know the
standard for being certain that that
person or keeping someone in jail really
is guilty is very different than if I'm
trying to decide whether to give someone
a job an issue that we saw addressed in
the cabin are hearing very quite
recently right the standard for putting
someone on the Supreme Court versus
putting someone behind bars should be I
think different right so the cost of the
false positives versus false negative
about that surely are different so I
write it so I agree with the idea that
that context has you know makes
different things salient the the cost of
false positive sources false negatives
in different contexts make a huge
difference for sure I agree with that
but the idea that you know we will throw
all our fairness measures out there and
if it passes all of them it's great and
if it fails all of them is probably bad
and and if it's passes some and fails
some it's somewhere in between that's
kind of appealing we were talking about
this last night but I have a worry that
all the interesting cases the ones that
really puzzle us are going to be in
those in-between cases so maybe it's not
going to be that helpful and that really
I think the issues are posed because
given injustice in society over time
race sex and other protected
characteristics are going to track with
a lot of qualities or traits that people
legitimately care about and so there's a
deep moral issue about how disruptive
you want to be of those correlations
and that's a moral question or a
normative question that we have to
address Nicole do you have a question hi
guys thanks very interesting commentary
I was curious I liked a lot of the
discussion of fairness so far has been
about the fairness of the outcome and
I'm wondering if there's two different
processes that lead to that same outcome
is their distinguishing like someone is
fair and one is not and we should prefer
one process to another or is it just
about the outcome I think it depends I
have trouble keeping it in the abstract
for some of these because the context in
this scenario is so important so tied to
how you would even measure it and so I
guess the answer is it depends on what
the scenario was I I think there that
those are different that process often
matters to fairness and in fact it shows
us why sometimes we don't care about say
treating like cases alike in a certain
sense that is the quintessential example
of a fair procedure is let's flip a coin
let's draw straws is is a lottery type
system or and that's not actually trying
to track anything about you know I'm
really choosing the people who have the
skills for the job it's just modeling
fairness as as procedure
so sometimes we care about fair
procedures sometimes we care about
getting the correct results where those
are independently determined and
sometimes we care about a little bit of
each I think so Mira I'm interested in
how your team actually measures fairness
and actually tests the systems that
you're building yeah so I'll give an
example and I'll make it
get the exact example but let's say we
were looking at a system that decides
who should come into this room or who
should not one of the things that we do
is we work with the team who's making
this design that algorithm and before we
even start collecting any data we start
running through the scenarios for how we
might operate around this system and so
we identify different groups of people
we call that subgroup classification and
so we're identifying there's different
categories of people that might end up
using it you might have children coming
in and out on the weekend but their
families you might have people with head
coverings you might have people coming
in on a rainy day and changes the
environmental factors as we start going
through all of the scenarios and we
create a set of stakeholders we create a
set of scenarios and then we use that to
decide how we're going to collect data
and so we use that to inform our data
collection effort and at the same time
that we're collecting data we start
deciding hey how do we set benchmarks
for the outcomes of these sub groups and
what kind of false positives do we want
to have what kind of error rates do we
want to have we start coming up with a
model around that and then as we start
designing our algorithms one of the
things we're trying to do is we've got a
whole platform we use and we call it our
dev inner loop so it's a place that
developers go and put their models in
and they test it against test data that
they might have just collected with
themselves they might have they might
test it against ground truth data that
we've collected explicitly and and then
they we're trying to put benchmarks in
place in that platform that can take our
estimates around error and false
positives and say okay how are we
performing now against this very tagged
data set that we used during our
scenario identification so it's
something we're testing out we haven't
finished going through that entire
system yet but but I think that this is
something that the team hasn't thought
of before I'll give you an example we
had a piece of hardware technology that
we were using to detect irises and
and gaze tracking and after a while we
realized that there was a category of
people that it just didn't work for we
weren't really sure why we thought we
had collected you know tens of thousands
of eyeballs we thought we had enough
quantity was more important at the time
instead of quality and we realized that
green eyeballs just perform differently
in the system and we didn't have enough
of them and they were actually hard for
us to collect and so some of the things
we we discover after the fact and we
discovered them through anomalies or
bugs and then it requires us to be
really thoughtful about understanding
why that happened because we may not
even I mean it's easy to think about
race and gender and those explicit
qualities but then there are things that
you don't typically think about I
wouldn't expect blue and green eyeballs
to perform differently as we're tracking
or they're looking that that was done a
while ago but you can imagine looking at
the system and how it's performing and
where you see bugs and anomalies we have
to go and dig deeper into that and do a
little bit more more work on it great so
you mentioned in your answer a couple of
different sort of application areas
there so seeing who should be let into a
room or not maybe tracking somebody's
eyes for some purpose and then there's a
bunch of other areas that you can think
of where machine learning is either
currently used or could be used and I'm
interested in getting some some
perspectives from the panelists about
what you think are the most important
areas in which tech companies will face
fairness issues I can start with a
couple one is oh sorry oh one is you
know there's a whole like employment is
one example so there was a whole panel
about LinkedIn before but so at LinkedIn
is a platform where it directly gives
you access to jobs let's say but there's
roundabout ways in which you can also
face these issues so for example there's
a company called hire view that records
people on camera
and then does a motion recognition on
them and then give that information to
the per to their people who are
interviewing the
the interviewers right and so the the
people who are providing like effective
OHS providing emotional recognition
technology to this company could I don't
know what how that would work like if
there was if it was found that they were
discriminating by certain attributes and
then that was you - that's a technology
the initial emotion recognition
technology or other things that they
were using from this third party like
company you know I think you know you
could face these kinds of things in a
roundabout manner - even if you're you
know providing face recognition
technology or some other thing that's
done is used by some third party entity
to you know make decisions about
people's lives I would agree that hiring
is a great example of a domain where you
want to be fair especially because for
what didn't it said before that if you
have a diverse group of people you can
make sure your products are fairer as
well so there's kind of a compounding
effect there if your products are not
working in certain neighborhoods or for
certain groups of people you're more
likely to notice that if you have a
diverse workforce so making fair out
hiring algorithms would help for that we
have a question over here yeah I do and
I guess in large part it's probably for
the board but I'm not sure so one thing
that came out especially say
applications like hiring and actually
from your story when I started raising
my hand that one way to figure out
fairness is to test for these groups
like test if the you know if the face
recognition works just as well for a
very dark faces then for light faces or
some other but there is a there's
aspiration of fairness they're protected
legally protected attributes that we may
not discriminate based on sex and race
and whatnot and I guess with this
data-driven word I think it's a very
natural idea that the only way we can be
fair if we actually use the protected
attribute in our decision-making for the
obvious reason because the protected
attribute is so correlated with a lot of
other stuff they're not using it
allow us to even test for the things
you're testing for but that this is a
legal question and maybe all of you but
you're the lawyer so yes maybe you you
know we are the legal community except
this
that's an order to be fair to the
protective groups the systems actually
have to use the protected attribute
that's the way to make it fair rather
than the you know idea that we are fair
to women if we don't use sex as an
attribute right so the legal system
unfortunately perhaps has Guam's on to
or focuses on to whether you use race
sex or some other protected
classifications as a classification but
you have to separate two different ways
that you might use it so that I'm
extrapolating I think from what you said
you tell me if I have gotten it right so
suppose you have a an algorithm that
doesn't use race or sex but after it
pops out a bunch of things you check to
see whether there are very few women in
the pool or very few racial minorities
in the pool so you're looking at the
results in terms of the racial
classifications produced and then
thinking well that's a that's not a
that's a too much of a disparate impact
on women or racial minorities so let's
revisit the stuff that goes into the
algorithm that I think is perfectly
permissible and I think in the
literature there's been this worried
that the court's decision in reaching
somehow which I can talk about later or
whatever somehow doesn't allow that and
I think that's a dramatic over reading
of Ricci I think that's perfectly
permissible but if one of the traits
that's actually in your algorithm is
racer sex I think you will get into
legal trouble and I think what you point
out about that is that's an unfortunate
effect of the way that currently our
legal system understands what's
prohibited and it's not something that's
easy to fix
because it's the courts interpretation
of constitutional law so well let me say
they
somewhat easy to fix if you're talking
about employers but not if you're
talking about the government so the
Constitution only affects governmental
actors but you know there are a lot of
governmental actors so I just want to
jump in here I recognize that I am NOT a
panelist so I will keep this very brief
I did write a paper on exactly this
topic this summer with a lawyer where we
looked at really the law and
specifically disparate treatment and
thought about ways in which it might be
okay to use those attributes one of the
scenarios that we looked at was the case
where those kinds of individual level
sensitive attributes are used during the
training process to develop your
classifier but then at deployment time
it has no such access to those
attributes and we argue that that is
fine from a disparate treatment
perspective the paper is not currently
online but probably will be online
within the next few weeks and I will
email you and let you know when it is
thank you
during the break before they all be
discrimination cases for college
admission Cornell engineering used to
have vane differently the SAT scores for
women and for men and the argument they
made which I actually supported an
argument that SAT scores on its own are
not something we care about we care
about them as a predictor of of college
performance and they had they thought to
show that the lower SAT scores for women
particularly famous it's a score for
woman predicts higher GPA and therefore
they can weigh up the GPS for women they
no longer do it because I guess it's not
legal but it's kind of sad they had a
point
so I which is that we are very focused
on US law and we have like companies
that are operating globally we have
machine learning conferences that are
international researchers that are
international in this area of fairness
is intertwined with with legal systems
and and how
I mean I don't know is how do he it was
and and our algorithms that were coming
up with the scenarios were coming up
with our very intertwined with US law
and I just I don't know how to address
that you know what do we do do you have
like different researchers in different
places and addressing it based on like
differently you know legalities should
we have one more intern international
law or something like this because this
comes up in privacy as well especially
with the GD P R at the moment which is
specifically Europe but yet we look at
companies like Microsoft that at
international companies and suddenly
that is applied everywhere not just
within Europe so I think this there's
perhaps stuff we can learn from some of
these other disciplines as well I think
it also ties into the first panel on
long-term thinking where maybe we should
think about what is ethical or fair in a
philosophical way also you know as
researchers and then maybe over time the
laws will change or catch up with that
that's also a very Western centric view
and one of the things we debate at
nauseam in our group is are we pushing
too much of a Western centric viewpoints
because we are an international
corporation and when you talk about
privacy and you look at other cultures
large parts of the world view privacy
and fairness quite differently than we
do in the western side of the world and
it's not something we have resolved
anything yet but it is a constant source
of tension and debate because because
there are such different viewpoints on
it and in certain cultures don't
emphasize individuals in the same way
versus collective and and so trying to
navigate that is a massive challenge for
us question over there
I've reinforced it sometimes there are
other areas where governments won't
expect that the rights of us governments
are accessed data are things that
question of what does
internationalization mean with a whole
bash of these questions and for
companies like Microsoft who sells
products globally how do you
parameterize those things it's not as
easy as changing the languages in and
out
you're changing moral codes in and out
and how do you represent that in your
systems new technology so what I was
gonna say that I think relates to that
point is that it's one thing if one
legal one legal regime has a standard
here and another one is just higher but
it's a totally different thing if they
actually conflict and I think around
discrimination they're more potentially
in conflict so the problems are a little
deeper than just you know a higher floor
I mean just to build on that a little
bit so Brad Smith published a blog post
calling for government regulation of
face recognition technology in July and
I want to sort of dig into this and say
is that the right approach and who
should be making decisions about what
makes a system fair or ethically okay is
it the government which government how
do you reconcile those differences or is
it companies like Microsoft or
developers or perhaps the people who are
going to be deploying these systems so
Deborah and I were talking about this
during lunch I think and in some cases
you have legal precedent to set the
floor and
we come in and say you know what we
don't think the floor is acceptable
enough and let's go a notch higher two
notches higher in other instances like
facial recognition technologies there is
no floor yet by set by the government
and so we could go in and say here's
what we think a potential floor is and
in brad smith's posts what he called on
was legislation to be used in this
category because because it's such a
critical piece and not just facial
recognition but I also think biometrics
and so in that one maybe corporations
who are doing technology work in the
space work alongside with regulators to
define the space educate each other and
it sort of sets a floor around behavior
there I would agree with them just add
one thing that legal legal answers or
legal interventions are gonna be more
cumbersome and often after the fact and
laws often tend to be more you know
they're not as targeted to a specific
problem that you know that that occurs
and so I think they'll even if you have
the law coming in there's always going
to be a role for companies to to
supplement that so I guess um I was
rather hoping an economist would ask
this question whether what's wrong with
just letting the market fix it like if
you're face recognition software is
biased then people aren't gonna buy it
and if you have these accurate data
sheets then you know they know what
they're getting and they can just not
buy something that doesn't do what they
wanted to do and you know if they do buy
it and they release a product that is
biased then people aren't gonna buy the
product and the company will go I think
the issue is like for me it's it's
pretty crazy that it took for a joy and
ice paper for like Kamala Harris
deciding it when she's you know writing
to the FBI and things like this people
have been using face recognition forever
right and so and they've been using in
law enforcement the companies have been
using it so so even though it was biased
for a long time people
have been using it so for me I'm not an
economist so I don't know much about
markets but for me this says the market
hasn't hasn't been fixing it and also a
lot of times I think that when you have
something that unfairly punishes
minorities it could be a minority of
people who don't really have a voice I
don't know if the market helps these
these people right I think this is
legislature in my opinion so I mean the
point of anti-discrimination law is to
protect groups that don't have either
the political power or the economic
power to protect themselves in the
marketplace which is why I'm actually
not worried about the green eyed eyeball
thing because the I think they're
actually you would expect the market to
self-correct
that the point of anti-discrimination
law is to protect those groups that
historically haven't been able either
economically or politically to protect
themselves
what's Genova that I keep on saying
minority and then joy always says that
under some sampled majority I love that
term understand which is a good example
of my point the data sheets are a good
step a step in the right direction
but if somebody's studies metadata and
information retrieval metadata itself is
socially constructed and has lots of
biases built in so we've we've got to
have all of what we really need here is
a governance process - there's a lot of
you know who's going to watch the
Watchers around metadata processes - so
I would add that to the fairness issues
great another question over there it was
actually more of a comment I was
mentioning it to you before I'm Tina yes
well for those of you who don't know me
I'm a professor at Northeastern
University I think it's not the job of
machine learning to fix the biases that
are in the data because our society is
broken I think the job of machine
learning is to show that the policies
are not being enforced correctly and go
back and change those policies so I
supposed to using machine learning to
make human decisions we should use
machine learning to show that the data
that's coming out of the enforcement's
of the policies are bad go to policy
makers and have the policies get changed
or the enforcement of it
how would that work and like let's say
hiring with it so I'm trying to
understand your question or at your
comment so when you have an automated
tool that's that that is then shown to
break certain laws that already exist
like let's say Equal Employment
Opportunity Act or something like that
then don't you think that the automated
tool itself should change to not break
that law so the question is that is the
algorithm doing the wrong thing or is
the data that you're giving from the
enforcement of the policy let's say stop
and frisk right so there's a stop and
frisk policy I have cameras on cops it's
taking data in and if I can from that
data reconstruct the intent of the
policy and then say look did you intense
your policy to do X - the policy maker
right and if the person says yes and
that the intent is oh wait a second stop
and frisk is stopping black and brown
people more than others and is that what
is your intent I bet most policy makers
will say no that was not my intent of
sovereign for us but the question is how
do you actually change society not that
oh I have to come up with a machine
learning algorithm because it's going to
be used in human decision-making because
we have all this data that's coming out
because the human decision-makers are
using it mostly for efficiency purposes
right that's why they like risk
assessments which are very bad in my
perspective because they don't give you
any uncertainty about the algorithm
right eight all right so Tina goes to
jail I don't think we would disagree
that it's a bad idea to use data to
point out problems we have with our
policies but at the same time our
systems are being used already today in
the world which is already biased and so
you have to do you have to make
decisions and you can say you know as a
company well it's unfair that you know
the number of applicants of minorities
and you know women for computer
companies is unbalanced and that poses
all kinds of problems we have in our
educational system and earlier on but we
don't want to just say let's wait until
they solve that and then when we have
5050 we have to make decisions today
y'all didn't have to make decisions in
where we are right now so I guess my
answer to that is that it's not that we
have to wait is that it has to be in
parallel right and the other one is that
what are the incentives of the decision
makers that are using your algorithms
right because it wasn't like before they
were using the data right I'm not saying
so so obviously we have stupid
algorithms right like mandatory minimum
sentencing that do not look at data
right but but the question is you have
to take into account incentives of the
people who are using your algorithms and
I don't think people are really looking
do that so I think I think all the cases
don't look like the stop-and-frisk kind
of case that there are some cases where
there's there are in justices or
unfairness --is in the past that I think
those of us who are in this world caring
about algorithms don't want to compound
those prior and justices and that's an
independent concern so one example I
like to use is insurance companies who
and this doesn't involve any you know
complicated AI but it would charge
domestic abuse victims more for health
and life insurance because if you're
being beaten up by your husband or
boyfriend you are more likely to need
health care life insurance now the
insurance company wasn't the one that
was responsible for the women being
beaten up and in fact even after you
left your batter you were most at risk
so they would charge them higher rates
even if they've left their batter but I
think the response to most people that
most people have is there's something
unfair about that and it's not that it's
not an accurate reflection of their
accurate actuarial risk and it's not
that the insurance company is somehow
responsible for perpetrating the
violence against these women yet still
you might think they shouldn't compound
that injustice that an injustice had
been done to someone and there's
something morally troubling about
carrying that injustice into another
domain now not only the woman got beaten
up but now she can't even get health or
life insurance so it's I think there are
a lot of situations that raise those
kinds of questions that I think are
important to think about I wanted to ask
a question back to the original idea
about fairness and so I have a lot
of concern about facial recognition ever
being used on balance better or well for
society than on balance injuring us as a
society and so one of the things that
I'm thinking a lot about is when does a
company or when does a technologist that
develops a system say this isn't going
to work in the way there's too much
unfairness and so I'm just I'm just
cutting bait it's done and I'd like to
know what the metric if that's ever
happened in your experience and what the
metric is and I'll just give you the
example in law there was a brief time
when the death penalty was a was
determined to be not working the way we
as a society needed it to work and so we
stopped in the United States
administering it we've now gone back to
it thinking that it's now working better
but there were metrics by which that was
being measured we could agree or
disagree about whether those are the
right metrics and whether it's still
working but I'd like to hear from a
technology perspective whether there
there's an indication that it is it is
so unfair or the outcome is so wrong
that we are going that we can't fix it
and a very good question I'm I'm
thinking a lot about this right now
because for example when our paper with
Joy's paper first came out some of what
some people were saying were was why are
you even so why are you trying to fix it
because we know that for
african-americans for example it's being
used unfairly and so even if it works
perfectly should we should we have this
technology I have a lot of thoughts
about this but I think the two things
are separate right like there's one
thing where you're showing disparity in
how something works and then the second
thing is what that thing is being used
for and so in in one way the fact that
we showed disparity I think helps people
now say we need to have legislation for
example in California right they the
Senate there was legislation passed on
the Senate floor or on the Senate floor
to say that before law enforcement uses
face recognition technology we have to
audit it in California it has so right
now that's not happening right everybody
was just using face recognition
technology the way they wanted it but at
least showing this disparity now starts
to have the conversation where the
public and our elected officials and
everybody else can can actually at least
make a decision about whether we want to
use it in certain can use cases or not
but I I don't support a complete ban on
face recognition to ignore don't want to
under any circumstances whatsoever I
mean I might change my mind if we if I
talk to other people about this because
there are some cases in which for
example you know when I fix you by the
emotion during cognition technology was
started Rana talks about how she was
working with kids with autistic kids and
how this was helping you know kids with
autism and people have written about
people older people with dementia and
how some of this technology might help
so so I don't I think you know I think
we have to look at it on a case-by-case
basis and for certain applications like
for example swinging people at the
airport there's too many false positives
I don't think it should be used for that
purpose
right then there maybe there's other
applications for which you might still
want to use it for Erik good there's a
good question you asked about you know
how do we make these decisions and just
in terms of a couple cases people here
might know about the ether committee at
Microsoft an advisory board that we have
Mira and Hannah serving on the folks on
that board helped to craft the the blog
that was written on face recognition and
recently certain recent cases that have
come to the board where Microsoft the
board itself and then the senior
leadership team of Microsoft said that's
okay that's okay you know something the
scenario were just not comfortable with
we're not doing that contract and
there's a reason a reasoning that goes
on typically it's not metric based or
accuracy based in this case it's we
don't understand that usage well enough
it's gonna work in terms of its
implications for human rights and
freedom of expression freedom assembly
how the errors are gonna work out in
real life we we have to study that
further and sometimes it doesn't
not to accuracy it's like even perfectly
accurate facial recognition perfectly
fair biometric that lets say one of our
several people on the panel man we with
even perfect recognition is that you can
cause a chilling effect when it comes to
freedom of expression and freedom of
assembly when used in a public square so
it depends on the usage in someone but I
can just make a comment here and it's
okay because we're gonna be going out
and being and we're gonna be public
about these I just whispered is this
being videoed because I because I wanted
that was not I was gonna engage my level
of precision like we're gonna be going
public about from these cases for
feedback without the names of the
various customers for example but it's
been we've actually had really
interesting deliberations on this
committee and working with their SLT and
we think we've said no several times and
yes several times and we try to take
those deliberations and the answers we
come up with across company and within
divisions has specifics that we try to
generalize into principles to make it
easier the next time around and then we
keep on watching the technology as it
evolves I hope that helps with the give
you examples so I just want to build on
that a little bit and say an Oscar
question about how technology companies
should be making those yes versus no
kind of decisions should we be using
some kind of ethical framework to guide
these decisions some set of ethical
principles that we've decided on or
should we be using some other means so I
think it's both of those plus I actually
really like what Microsoft has put in
place because there's various levels of
thinking and checks and balances at the
corporate level the ether board is
looking across the company at scenarios
and then generalizing that into broad
guidelines broad principles that you can
then go and take and apply at the local
level and then there are groups like
mine there's actually another group
that's similar in how they operate that
go and do governance at a local level
and say okay we have these principles
now how do we apply it at a local level
how do we apply these principles of
fairness accountability transparency
privacy all of these are technologies
around face recognition speech
recognition and so this sort of two-tier
model I think is very interesting
because it lets us scale and and operate
at like what corporate decisions do we
want to make and what do we say yes and
no - and then locally how do we put
things in place around tooling around
culture change and educating people
around changing how we do our design and
development and that's happening at a
very local level because it is very
specific to the culture of the team the
technology they're working on but having
this sort of lathering up I think is a
very interesting model to explore
because it lets you cover very different
audiences and very different needs and
and moves the company forward in a
positive way because if you just have
the corporate level what would happen is
it would be PR speak and would just be
talk that it was very hard to translate
into how we apply it if you just have
the applied level you wouldn't have the
broad company orientation and so I think
that these two groups to me it's a
fascinating experiment and there's
something very good about that that I
think other companies could model great
well with that we are out of time thank
you everybody let's thank our panelists
you
[Applause]